Hi!
Hello, I'm back!
Oh my god, I'm back!
Hi!
That's good to know.
Hiiii!
Hellooooo!
I'm back!
Oh my god, I'm back from being banned on YouTube!
I'm back from being banned on YouTube!
Hello!
For, um, chewing on the ears.
Wa wa!
Thank you for watching!
Thank you for, uh, the membership.
The best little ginger-
The best little ginger sister, Imi, is back.
You're never allowed to leave again, understood?
Big bro will cry if you're gone too long?
It wasn't my fault!
Okay?
I thought chewing on the ears would be okay.
I thought it would be okay.
Welcome back, Travelmaker.
Mmmmmm...
Did you spank Esteban?
I didn't know.
It's been so long, uh, something, something.
This is behind the slaughter.
What?
Are you talking about Five Nights at Freddy's?
Thank you for all the membership.
Missed you glad you're back.
I'm so happy to be back.
I got punished!
I got punished by YouTube. I mean, I wasn't gonna stream much anyways because my cousin was over.
Oh my god, thank you for all the memberships. Holy shit. Holy shit.
Frick JonTube, yeah. JonTube? What?
Welcome back. Punishment time for me?
Maybe later in a few days.
How do I have days? So I'm thankful for you and the pin pals. I love you so much. Kiss, kiss.
Oh, you did so good waiting for me. Thank you for waiting. Thank you.
Missed you so much. I missed you too. I missed you so much. I'm so happy I'm back.
Thank you for all the memberships. Thank you for renewing them and stuff.
Longest week ever. For me too, man, I did so much in like such a little amount of time.
Oh, thank you for the five minutes. What do people call these on YouTube memberships?
The five minutes. The gifted. Gifted. Thank you for the five gifted.
You have no idea how much I missed you. You're never allowed to leave again.
I'll, I'll try not to. I'll be on my best behavior on YouTube.
I'll be on my best behavior because I can, I can, I can do other stuff on other websites now.
Felt like a month. I know it felt like a month for me too.
It felt like a month for me too.
I hated waiting. I hated it.
Keep, keep the sauce on brosley. We don't ever, so we don't ever lose you on YouTube.
I'll keep it on brosley. It's funny how you call it brosley. I've never called it brosley.
Oh yeah, I forgot. Thank you for 30K.
Thank you for 30K. Holy crap. I like, it just happened while I was gone.
I had a goal of 30K for a month and a half.
Or I guess a month now because it's already been half a month. I wanted to hit 30K in a month.
Why are you acting so gay?
I'm not a messed up $10. Welcome back, Emmy.
Thank you. Thank you for the $10. Thank you. I'm happy to be back.
Um, just gifted zero memberships. What? Why did I say that? Is that a glitch?
50K next? I mean, eventually.
Wait, did I read that wrong?
Wait, why did it say zero memberships for me?
Oh, five. Thank you for the five. Okay, I said that already. Sorry. The notifications are, um, are delayed.
Okay, almost at 35K. We are. I mean, don't go to 50K next. We gotta reach 40K first.
But I don't know, I don't know if, um, I don't know if we'll get there.
Also chat is broken. I don't know why. I think it's broken for other streamers too.
I remember seeing something like that in our server. They talked about how it was broken.
Oh, yeah. Um, hello, little Emmy. It's an honor to meet you and your pin pals.
I'm new around here. I wanted to say hello. I'm new to Vealert. Hello, welcome to Vealert.
I hope you have fun here. We're an interesting bunch, for sure.
Chat's been buggy this week. Yeah.
It has been. I don't know how to fix it yet, so we're just not gonna have chat.
Yep. Yep. They specifically did it because of me. They wanted to punish me.
They wanted to take away my chat privileges, but they couldn't do that because then that would be show...
What's the opposite of favoritism? Hateism. Hating.
They hate me specifically and they wanted to punish me, but they already gave me a strike.
So they were like, you know what, let's just take away chat too.
Love you forever. Oh, I love you too. Thank you.
Dude, that's wholesome right here.
You should check out Strawny if you like dude, that's wholesome. I heard that they sound similar.
Disfavoritism. Yeah. Hateism. I don't know.
Prejudice. They're prejudiced against me specifically.
Okay. I'm so tired. I've had a rough fucking week.
I'm gonna lean back.
I've had a rough week because I like...
I went to multiple cities and to like multiple attractions and like...
I should lean forward. I don't want to lean forward.
And like theme parks and stuff. So like, I'm really tired.
It's been a really long trip and yeah. Kind of a tour guide. A little bit.
Do you still have monsters? I don't. I drank them all a long time ago.
I'm not the only one who thinks they sound the same. Yeah, a lot of...
A lot of people think Strawny and dude, that's wholesome sound the same.
Has it been a roller coaster? It has been. Both emotionally and physically and also...
I've been on roller coasters.
I guess I can tell you a bit about the trip.
You're not allowed to leave us again for the whole year. I'll try...
Oh, here.
It's like coming back to your Animal Crossing Island. Calls you a slur. Love you and me.
It's been two years and three weeks and ten days.
Alright, wait. And six days.
Because ten days is another week. Right? Yeah, yeah.
Did you enjoy yourself?
I had moments where I enjoyed myself, but I also had moments where I really, really, really wasn't having fun.
So it was like a mix of both, kind of.
That doesn't make any sense. Strawny has an accent and dude, that's wholesome, doesn't it?
They cannot sound the same.
He's lacking critical information.
Um, anyways.
Two years, three months, three weeks and six days!
I'm sorry to hear you having a rough time. If you're alright, I'll gladly...
me another big bro to add the c- to the f- I can't read.
You sound like you need more brothers.
I only have one brother and it's you.
Did you drink at all? No, I didn't drink while I was out there.
I'll tell you why I'm afraid of planes, but that...
I want to talk to you first a little bit. We gotta catch up a little bit first.
It's been ten days since I last streamed, really? Holy crap.
That feels really long.
Um...
Um, so...
Basically, I, um...
So, I wasn't the only tour guide, right?
My cousin came, you know, to visit us.
But, um, I, we, we all went.
Me, my cousin, um, my uncle, and his girlfriend, and his girlfriend's friend.
We all went together!
So, um...
Like, we all went together to go places.
I wasn't, you know, I wasn't driving around or anything because I didn't know how to drive.
So, it was kind of like, um...
It was a lot of people, and I don't know...
I don't know my uncle's girlfriend very well, and I don't know...
I didn't know at all my uncle's girlfriend's friend!
So, um, I...
It was kind of awkward a little bit, and so I made sure to get a separate hotel room from them because I was like...
It'll, it'll, it'll, you know, um...
I'll avoid some of the awkwardness, and also, um...
Also, um, like, my uncle and his girlfriend smokes a lot.
Like, a lot, and they were smoking in the car the whole time,
and I was like, I am absolutely not staying in a hotel room with you guys because you're gonna smoke in the fucking hotel room.
And, um, like, I think I tweeted about it.
I was like, I fucking hate people who smoke!
I did tweet about it.
Oh, hold on, I have to open...
Thank you for the $4.20.
Let me open it.
I should write in the description somewhere.
TTS only activates for $5 an app.
I really need to write that somewhere, so people know.
Uh...
Hey, Amy, I know Poppy Playtime has been pissing you off.
How about a new horror game?
I've been seeing YouTubers play FNAF into the pit,
and it looks easier to play than Poppy Playtime.
I'm actually already playing that next week.
Fuck, I keep doing that frog blank, man.
I mean, I still haven't fixed that frog blank.
Ahem, yeah.
Um, we're playing Poppy Playtime next week.
Not Poppy Playtime.
We're playing Five Nights at Freddy's into the pit next week already.
I already, I already, um...
Fuck, I did it again! What the fuck?!
Fuck!
Um...
Keep the frog blank?
I think it looks bad, though.
I already, I already plan to do that, yeah.
In the description should be good.
I have to update, like, my default description.
Yeah.
I used to smoke but quit since that shit got way too expensive.
It is, it is expensive.
But they, not only do they smoke, um...
Sorry, I'm rubbing my eye, hold on.
I have something in my eye.
Um, not only do they smoke, like, cigarettes,
but they smoke the devil's lettuce!
They smoke the devil's lettuce, like, okay.
And, um, it smells really bad to me,
and it makes me, like, nauseous.
And also, you still have a debut in your description?
I know.
I think that's supposed to be there, though.
I don't know.
They smoke kale.
And it smells really bad to me,
and, um, my, my uncle's girlfriend
was, like, trying to pressure my cousin into,
into smoking with her.
And it was kind of awkward,
because it's like, my cousin obviously didn't want to,
but she was the only other, like, person...
Thank you for becoming a member.
Two months, I know!
It's been two months!
Yippee!
Um, but she was the only person
that my, um, uncle's girlfriend, like, knew
would be open to smoking,
because it's kind of funny.
We were in the car, and, um, I don't know.
We were talking about something,
and my uncle was like,
oh, yeah, Amy thinks people who smoke weed are losers,
and I was like, yeah, I do, actually, yeah.
And then his girlfriend turned around,
and she was like, huh?
Wait, wait, what?
And then I was like, oh, wait, wait, wait.
No, I don't mean you're a loser.
I don't mean you're a loser.
I just mean, I just mean there's a correlation.
I'm sorry.
Anyone who smokes weed here,
I kind of defended you, I'm sorry.
It's just, it's just a correlation between...
Listen, okay, I've been around smokers my entire life,
and I'm tired of it, so I...
I've gotten to a point where I get really annoyed at this point
about it, especially when it's like...
I don't know, you can't wait until, like, we get to, um...
Like, you can't wait until we get to, like, a stop.
You have to do it in the car with us.
Like, you can't wait until we get to the hotel.
You can't wait until we're outside.
You know what I mean?
Like, you have to do it with me here.
I don't know.
It annoyed me a lot, so, yeah.
That's something that I hate.
What's your thoughts on people drinking?
Um...
I mean, obviously, excessively is bad, but drinking doesn't...
It, like, someone drinking near me doesn't make me feel nauseous, you know?
So it's like, whatever, you can drink near me or just...
You can drink near me or around me.
Just don't bother me about it, like, you know?
Just don't do it excessively, like, a lot and often.
Welcome back.
We missed you.
Looking forward to some quality time with this this week to make up for it.
I'll try.
Um...
So, yeah, I don't mind drunk driving yet.
Also, don't do it while you're driving, of course.
Of course.
It's so jover.
My sister hates me.
I'm sorry.
Why are you acting so gay?
I know how you feel in me.
All my siblings and all my cousins smoke except...
Everyone except me.
I even once cut my parents with some edibles once after a New Year's party.
Accidentally ate one and had the trip of my life.
Mmm.
I haven't...
I've tried an edible before, too.
Uh-oh.
I didn't feel anything, though.
So, I was okay.
But it was just, um...
Like, yeah.
It's not even just, like, you know, family.
It's like...
Like...
It is family.
Yeah, it is family.
But it was like, ever since I was like a baby.
Like, I've lived with people smoking in my house.
And so, now that I moved out, I have, like, no more tolerance for it.
Because I hated it so much as a kid.
And I finally...
I finally had a taste of freedom!
And clear lungs!
This edible ain't shit!
Yeah.
Um...
This week has banger streams, really?
Does it?
That's good.
Raise hell.
Praise Dale.
If you ain't drunk, you ain't driving.
What does that mean?
The only kind of drunk driving that I encourage is drunk driving in Mario Kart.
No one wants to secondhand smoke two packs a day.
Exactly.
Ah, real.
Real and true.
It's so bad when you smoke you don't realize how bad it is until you quit.
I mean, I don't realize that all because I never did.
But, um, it does get really bad and stinky, yeah.
But what else we...
So we went to a theme park?
I was so pissed about this.
Okay, so my uncle texted me and he was like, you know,
can you buy the tickets for the theme park?
And I was like, sure!
I'll buy the tickets for the theme park, right?
I texted back.
I'm like, I want to get fast passes.
I want to get fast passes for the people that want to go on rides.
Because, fuck, I keep doing that frog blink.
I don't know why.
Let me turn down my lighting, maybe.
I want to get fast passes for the people that want to go on rides.
Because every time I've ever been to a theme park,
I had to wait in line like the rest of the losers.
And this time, I have enough money to not do that.
So, I tell him, I'm like, okay.
Who wants a fast pass?
Who should I get a fast pass for, right?
And he says, um, his girlfriend?
Obviously me, because I want one.
And my cousin, right?
And I'm like, cool, okay.
I'll get a fast pass for all three of us.
Yeah, who waits in line like a loser, exactly.
I do.
I always do.
But, um, I do that, right?
I do that.
I spend like a crazy amount of money on tickets,
because it's like a popular theme park.
And, um, we get there, right?
We get there, okay?
My cousin goes on one big ride.
They have multiple big rides,
but she goes on one big ride, right, with us.
And, uh, my uncle doesn't go on any rides,
because he's scared of them.
But his girlfriend likes ride.
So, likes big rides, right?
And I'm okay with them, too.
So, my cousin goes on one big ride with us,
all the way at the start of our visit to this theme park.
And then she's like, I'm done.
I don't want to do this anymore.
I can't do this anymore.
I, I, and so the rest of the time,
it's literally just me and my uncle's girlfriend
going on every single ride together.
I don't even know this girl that well.
But it's just me and her going on rides together.
And it's just, and my, my uncle and my cousin
are just like following us around,
because my uncle never intended to go on rides,
because he's scared.
But my cousin, like, why did I get a fast pass for her?
I was so pissed, because, like, it was like,
it was a lot of money.
I'm not gonna, it was, it was, it was, I was so pissed.
I was so pissed.
Because the only one she ended up going on
was at the end of the day,
after we had already, after me and,
and my uncle's girlfriend already went on all the big rides
and we were like tuckered out and we were like,
okay, the, the theme park is closing soon.
So, you know, we should get ready to leave.
You know those, those spinning teacup rides?
Those spinning teacup rides?
Um, she went on those at the end of the day.
That's the second ride she went on.
That's all.
I went on them with her, too.
And my uncle got the, he, he grew the balls to go
on the spinning teacup, too.
So that was nice.
Um, I mean, wait, please tell me you spun it
as hard as you could.
No, they don't have, they didn't have the wheels
to spin it yourself.
Um, it just automatically spins.
It went pretty fast, but, um, it was,
it just, it just, like, you can't control the speed of it.
A little baby went on the teacups.
I know I should have, I should have teased her for it more.
I should have.
I'm also bad when it comes to rides,
but only the spinning teacups is crazy.
I know.
It wasn't, it wasn't, was it 150 or 300 for fast passes?
I'm not going to tell you guys,
but it was somewhere between those two numbers.
Let's just say that.
It was definitely between those two numbers.
Um, you'll really let the brat chances pass you by.
What brat chances?
Like to, to tease her for it.
And, um, you know, not make fun of her enough
for, for being a little fuzzy.
And what's crazy is they wanted to go skydiving the next day.
My cousin was going to go skydiving the next day.
With my, with my uncle's girlfriend,
they were both going skydiving.
She wasn't afraid to go skydiving,
but she was afraid to go on roller coasters.
And I was so confused because I was like,
you're going to jump from like,
I don't fucking know, 10,000 feet in the air.
And you're, you're afraid to go on a roller coaster
that doesn't even get any close to that high in the air.
You know what I mean?
Like, I don't know.
It was just kind of like, is it,
is it because she's scared of the ride malfunctioning?
She did say that she didn't trust the machinery,
but at the same time it's like, you trust a parachute?
You don't trust, you don't trust a roller coaster,
but you trust a parachute?
Like, that's gross.
I don't know.
She's very strange.
She's a very strange person for sure.
I had fun with her, but it was definitely,
there were definitely times where she's, she's strange,
and I had to kind of be the person to like...
I'm going to need revoke your brat license.
No, don't revoke it.
I'll act like a brat.
Just, just give me some time.
I need to get back in my bratty mood.
To be fair, skydiving and roller coasters
have entirely different g-force directions.
I don't know.
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
Um, I feel like if Big Bro took me to a theme park,
she would probably do some magic on your wand
while we rode the ferris wheel.
Absolutely not!
They have cameras in there!
They have cameras in the ferris wheel!
They can see you doing that!
And they'll, they'll, they'll tell you on the microphone,
hey, we can see you, please stop.
Um...
Maybe she was feeling like puking?
I don't think that was the case.
Skydiving and roller coasters...
Oh wait, I already read that.
You do have two extra shoots for backup.
I thought you only had one extra.
I don't know.
I'll trust a roller coaster over a parachute any day.
Me too!
Like, even if it does get stuck somewhere,
like, you're still, you probably won't get stuck upside down.
I know if, I know what's happened where people have gotten
stuck upside down during a roller coaster,
but you probably, if, like, most roller coasters
only go upside down for, like, a short amount of time,
and then they, like, you know,
they go, like, up and down and stuff, right?
Like, if somehow it malfunctions
and maybe it stops moving,
you'll probably just get stuck, like, in a normal position,
you know?
Or, like, I guess the worst-case scenario is that it, like,
you know, detach, like, the cart detaches from the, um,
from the rails and you go flying.
And sure, sure you might die, sure,
but I feel like you're, you had a,
you have a higher chance of dying during skydiving anyways.
Speaking of puke wins the audio, what fucking audio?
I'm not, uh, puking audio?
What do you mean?
When you're flying, you have a chance to hit rock bottom.
What do you mean, rock bottom?
There's more than just cameras stopping me.
There's more than just cameras.
Um...
My harness came unlocked once,
and that's why I don't dress them no more.
Like, roller coasters or skydiving.
My harness came unlocked once, too,
while I was on a roller coaster.
I ended up fine, though.
Like, usually, um,
because that's why they have two seatbelts, you know?
They have, like, the one that goes across your hips
and then they have the one that goes,
um, above you, you know?
I can't believe you muted during that stream.
Oh, where I puked, sorry.
I don't automatically assume that people want to hear me puke.
I'm really sorry about that.
Okay, um...
What else?
We went to...
We went to, like, a sports game.
We went to some sports game,
because my cousin's into sports,
so I was like,
sure, I'll come with you and watch this sports game.
Even though I don't really care about it,
I came with her, and it was just meh.
I don't know.
I didn't have any sort of...
I kind of just sat there with her,
and then, like,
we initially got, like, tickets that were really shitty,
but she's like,
follow me.
I've done this before.
And she, like, leads me to where, like, there's better seating,
and she, like, waits until the, like, staff
guarding the seat, like, thing,
guarding the...
I don't know, guarding the entrance to those seats,
like, walks away,
and she, like, sneaks us into better seats.
Which was nice.
Watch men play with a ball.
No.
It was, like, a woman's sports game.
It wasn't...
It wasn't a men's sports event.
I know, what a couple of delinquents.
I know.
We were breaking the law together over there.
Good thing we didn't get caught.
Someone would have called the police on us.
And then, um, what else did we do?
No, no, we just went to, like, attractions.
It was kind of annoying because we had to, like,
wait in line for tickets,
and it was really busy,
because it was, like, a weekend.
Um...
We did go to an escape room,
which was nice.
That was really cool.
We went to an escape room.
So, like, my, um...
What's it called?
Um...
My uncle, like, had to work the next day,
so he only stayed with us in that city
for a little bit,
and then he left.
He left.
And we had to find our way home alone,
which was fine.
I've done that before.
So, um...
We did an escape room together,
like, 30 minutes before we had to catch the bus to leave,
and that was really stressful,
because we were trying to finish the escape room
before we had to leave,
and we actually managed to do it,
and it was really fun.
I really wanted to do an escape room again,
because that's the first time I ever did it,
and every time I, like...
Every time I managed to solve a puzzle,
I was like,
ah, so smart.
She never escaped from there.
I did escape.
We managed to escape, um,
in time to catch the bus.
Barely, barely.
The Uber driver was, like, speeding
to get us to the bus station in time,
but we managed to catch it.
You can't even beat the puzzles in Poppy Playtime?
Okay, well, I beat a lot of the puzzles
in the escape room.
I just...
It's the pressure of having people watch me,
you know, while I'm playing Poppy Playtime,
but I didn't have anyone watching me
while I was doing the escape room puzzles,
so I was fine.
And I was smart.
Like I always am when you're not watching.
It's just a clone, really.
I mean, you're still trapped in the escape room.
The difference between your puzzle abilities,
IRL, and during games is amazing.
That's true, too.
That's true, too, because I don't really play puzzle games,
so I'm not used to playing them,
but, like, I can do puzzles in real life.
Yeah, it's the streamer debuff.
Exactly.
It's just the streamer debuff.
Um...
I'm gonna keep this stream a little shorter, though.
I have some bad news to give you.
I don't want to give you the bad news.
Um, I'll keep it short.
I'll keep it short and sweet.
So, um...
Esplan had surgery recently,
and, um, she's not...
She was initially doing okay,
but she deteriorated, like, really fast.
Um...
She's still alive,
but she's not doing good,
so I'm really worried about her,
and I don't want to be away from her very long.
I've been, like, sitting with her on my chest,
like a little baby.
She's so, um...
Why are you acting so gay?
I'll thank you for the $1.
Does that mean we're...
When we're watching you on Brosly,
you're gonna get stage fright?
Does that mean when we're watching you on Brosly,
Yeah, of course!
Of course.
Of course I'm gonna have stage fright.
Yes, I will be nervous.
Yeah, I've been, like, sitting with her, um,
on my chest and just, like, petting her.
I am worried about her.
I don't like to be away from her for long.
So, yeah.
I did go to the vet again, yeah.
She, um, he gave...
He gave me some medicine.
She has to take, like, three different medications.
Um...
Yeah.
I'm worried about her.
Um, let me pull up my...
presentation.
I don't know how to make it fullscreen.
Is it?
Okay, wait, if I...
Mmm, I don't like that.
I'm just trying to figure out
how to show you my presentation here.
Can I open it with...
Poopoo...
Poopoo Chrome?
No, I don't want to open it like that.
Mmm.
I hope she pulls through.
I hope so, too.
What if I move...
Mmm.
What if I move it here?
Does that work?
No.
Let me try again.
Here it is.
Okay.
There we go.
Can I make this fullscreen?
Presents!
There we go!
Okay.
Um, since I haven't been here in long,
I don't know you had oolomark at March.
I bought an acrylic stand and I'm excited to get it.
Oh!
I bought my merch, too.
For someone else, not even for me.
I didn't even buy my merch for myself.
I'm buying it for one of my friends.
I'm not scared of flying in an airplane.
I'm scared of flying...
I'm trying to fly out of the airplane.
What does that mean?
Trying to fly out of the airplane?
I'm sorry to hear about Esteban.
Hi, Amy. I've been watching your clips for the past few days.
Oh, thank you.
Hello, hello.
I'm still waiting on my merch, too.
It hasn't been sent out.
This is the right thing.
I'm scared of being yeeted out of the airplane.
Me, too.
I'm scared of that, too.
Oh, oh.
Um...
I think...
Uh...
I mean, I meant to if I were 3,000 feet up,
I'd rather be on the inside of the plane than in...
I'd rather be on the inside of the plane
than inside.
You mean outside, right?
I'd rather be on the inside than the outside.
I'm scared of falling out of planes, too,
but that's not...
That's not the least of your worries
as you'll learn here in my presentation.
Alright.
Here...
Here's my presentation.
Oh, you can't see...
Oh, fuck. Hold on.
Okay, there you can see...
You can see the plane's scary face.
Look how scary he looks.
Um, he's evil.
All planes are evil.
All airlines and planes are evil.
And don't get on one because you'll die if you do.
Okay.
Let me explain to you
why airplanes are the scariest, most terrifying,
horrific mode of transportation.
And I'm not being irrational.
I'm not being unrealistic.
I'm not being irrational.
I'm not being delusional.
I'm not being...
I'm being so...
real right now.
Not all planes, just the Boeing ones.
All planes. Every single one of them.
They're all evil.
That's what they want you to think, but they're all bad.
I'm not being paranoid. I swear I'm not being paranoid, okay?
Okay.
Statistically, roads should be scarier than skies.
Yeah, that's what you would think.
That's what they want you to think.
Okay, that's what they've been telling you
so that you get on the plane.
But I'm going to tell you the truth right now.
Hold on. You know how Strani was wearing a...
Hold on.
You know how Strani was wearing a...
the tinfoil hat
and her thing?
I need to get myself a tinfoil hat.
Hold on.
Tinfoil hat.
Can I get it?
Hat. PNG.
This is perfect.
Oh, it's so ugly.
That's not a real PNG.
I hate when they beat me with fake PNGs.
Like the ones with a background,
but they have like the checkered background.
That's so stupid.
Download.
Oh, I also hate when they
make me feel like the PNG is free,
but I actually have to pay for it.
Just give me a free PNG of a tinfoil hat.
Is that so fucking hard?
Ahem.
Is this one good?
I'm not going to allow ads.
No.
No, I'm not going to allow ads.
That one's so bad.
What about this one?
Leave me alone.
Not allowing ads.
Okay, is this going to be a real PNG
or fake PNG?
Is this going to be a virus?
I want to download.
Let's see.
It's a real PNG.
Okay.
Let me put it on.
Um...
What the fuck?
No.
I'm bad with computers. Hold on.
Copy.
Streaming assets.
Items.
Okay.
They brainwashed you!
They brainwashed you all!
Everyone in the aviation industry
that has been brainwashed,
and I'm going to tell you the real truth
and I'm the only one you can trust.
Okay?
Okay.
Okay, anyways, let me find
my tinfoil hat here.
That I put it in here.
Where is my tinfoil hat?
Are you shitting me?
Are you so bad at putting pictures into VTube Studio?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Perfect.
Are you ready?
Yeah, he's from Boeing.
He's sponsored by Boeing.
Don't trust him.
Don't trust what he says. Trust what I say.
All right.
Um, oh fuck.
Hold on, hold on, let me present it.
Okay.
Why airplanes are the scariest,
most terrifying, horrific mode of transportation
and I'm not being irrational? Are you ready?
Okay.
Oh fuck.
Okay, disclaimer.
This presentation is just for fun
and for comedic purposes.
Please don't try to argue with me
or disprove what I'm saying.
There are two facts and logic here.
Only vibes and planes have bad vibes.
If some of my info is wrong,
just pretend you didn't see it
because I didn't say it if it's wrong
because I'm never wrong, okay?
They're flying metal death tubes
that weigh hundreds of tons
and we're just meant to believe that they belong in the sky.
No, I don't buy it exactly.
That's the kind of
attitude I'm looking for
in chat, okay?
That's the kind of attitude
I'm looking for.
Is there chocolate under the tinfoil?
No, it's not a Hershey's kiss.
It's not a kiss.
Okay.
So here's my table of contents.
This is what we'll be going over.
Sorry, I know I'm really fucking,
I'm really fucking big here
but I tried to include some nice pictures
to keep your attention
because that's what they told me in school.
Whenever you're making a presentation,
you got to
make it attractive to the eye
so I did my best to do that.
Right, so I have my introduction
how it all started. You know how I started
disliking planes.
I'm going to disprove some lies
that airlines have told you.
Have made you believe.
They want you to think it's safe
because they want your money.
If everyone knew the truth about planes,
then airlines wouldn't be making
any money.
I'm going to tell you everything
that can go wrong.
Why are you acting so gay?
Well, I used to be run by engineers
who made sure that their planes worked
until they started being run by accountants
who cut corners on safety and maintenance
to save a few bucks. That's what I'm going to go into
actually.
That's exactly what I'm going to talk about.
Not specifically bowling,
but like in general,
like, yeah, cutting corners.
I'm sorry, I'm trying to
I'm trying to read the doughnos, but
I'm getting stuck on the
on the tab.
Hey, Amy,
what's the safest seat on the airplane?
I can tell you. You know why?
You've never seen an airplane
fly backwards into a mountain, have you?
No, I haven't. I was going to say that, yeah.
The safest seat on the airplanes
are the ones in the back and in the middle.
The back and the middle are the safest.
What was the other donation?
Thank you for the $10.
Just remember, Amy, planes disappear all the time
in Bermuda Triangle. I'm not trying to go on a flight in advantage.
Actually, the Bermuda Triangle
is fake and gay. I don't believe in the Bermuda Triangle,
but I do believe in planes disappearing
randomly.
Okay.
Um, okay.
Here's a table of contents and then finally,
I'm going to end on, um, you will die.
You will die.
If something goes wrong, you will die.
We're all going to die.
Everyone.
Maybe like one or two people are going to survive, maybe.
But if something goes wrong, you're dead, okay?
And I'm going to tell you why.
Okay, here's my
introduction.
I...
I don't know why that emoji is gray.
It's yellow for me on my monitor.
I don't know why it's gray.
I'm going to ignore that.
Alright.
How it all started.
I got to move myself.
Right. How it all started.
So as a kid, I wasn't scared of airplanes.
I flew a lot as a kid, actually.
I was not afraid of them. I was not afraid of falling out of the air.
I was mostly okay.
Because I was stupid and I didn't know the truth yet.
I didn't know how dangerous they were.
I only really disliked them.
Because they make my ears hurt a lot.
And they still make my ears hurt to this day.
Not as bad as when I was a kid,
but still really, really bad.
Um...
It's like the pressure change, right?
The pressure change makes your ears hurt.
Um...
And no, don't try to give me advice.
Oh, just chew on some candy. Just chew on some gum.
Chewing on anything doesn't help.
Blowing through my...
Blowing through my nose while plugging it doesn't help.
Sucking on candy doesn't help.
Nothing helps, okay?
Nothing helps me.
And that's why I hate it. It hurts.
The only thing that helps...
A tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny little bit
is yawning.
Yawning helps a teeny, tiny little bit.
And I'm constantly yawning on a plane.
And it makes my jaw hurt.
Because it's the only thing that helps.
And so I'm literally just sitting there like...
Like the whole time
on the plane because it hurts
so badly.
And I'm trying to get my ears to...
I don't know.
I don't know what you're supposed to stop
popping like that, you know?
Anyways,
one time when I was a kid,
I fell asleep while the plane was taking off.
Because I was so tired from flying on planes
because I can't sleep on planes.
That's another reason I hate them.
I didn't include this on the presentation,
but fucking airlines want to make
money so they make the seats so tiny
that you're not comfortable.
So you can't fall asleep on them.
As a kid, I could fall asleep on them a little bit
because I was like tiny. I was a small little kid.
Now, absolutely not.
No way in hell can I fall asleep on a plane.
I'll get like... I can doze off
for like five minutes at a time
maybe because I'm so sleep deprived.
But otherwise, I cannot sleep
on a plane. I need to get like first class
tickets where I can lay down completely
horizontally because
if I'm in that tiny stupid economy class
seats, I can't sleep.
Like, I can't do it.
I'm really, I'm really
passionate about hating planes.
Okay.
Um, yeah, sorry. I fell asleep on a plane
one time when I was a kid while I was
taking off and I woke up as it was
landing. And so that means I didn't
like yawn or anything or
to try to fix my ears.
Um, and so
when I woke up, I literally couldn't even hear
anything for half the day afterwards.
And my ears were in so much pain
and my mom was like good morning
in me and I was like
I can't hear anything.
Like it was so, it was, everything
was so um
I can't think of the word
like um
muffled. Everything was so, so, so
so muffled.
Um, I hated that, I hated that
and that's why I never, even if I
am tired, I try to wait
at least like until the plane is
all the way up to even just
relax. Just to relax
and like
sit back
and like, I don't know
de- de- de- de- stress a little bit
but while it goes up I'm like
ahhh
yawning a little time.
I'm freaking the fuck out because it's going
too fast and it's going
it's going up too fast shit like that
and it's really bumpy sometimes.
Um, but now when I'm older
I've realized that I should have
been scared when I was a kid.
I should have been pissing myself and shit in
myself because I could have died.
I could have died.
Okay.
Next, next slide.
Ahem.
Alright.
Now I'm going to disprove some lies
that airlines tell you because they want to
make money, right? They're not going to
they're not going to tell you the truth.
They're not going to tell you the truth because
if they told you the truth then you wouldn't
be buying airplane tickets
because you don't want to die, obviously. No one wants
to die. Especially not on an airplane
because that's the most terrifying way
to die. It's like, it's like a death roller coaster
basically except like
you could get flung out of your seat.
Hahaha.
So it's even worse than a death roller coaster
because at the end you'll die
but you might die in the middle too.
Or at the start. It really depends
what happens.
Anyways.
Disproving airline lies.
So, here's some lies
that airlines, there's something wrong with my
there's something wrong with my windowcapture.
I don't know.
Here's some lies that airlines have told you
and why they're fake.
Number one.
Airplanes are safer than cars.
There's only
one crash, one airplane crash
out of bajillions of flights, right?
So you shouldn't even worry
because your chances of getting into a crash
are like slim to none, right? WRONG!
WRONG! WRONG!
Because crashes aren't the only thing that
can go wrong, okay? Crashes aren't the only thing
that can go wrong.
Oh, there's so little deaths.
There are still deaths and there are horrific deaths.
There are freak accident deaths
and I'm scared of dying in a freak accident.
Is that so wrong?
Is that so wrong to be afraid of dying in a freak accident?
I don't think so. Okay, here's the truth.
I don't care about the crash stats, okay?
If something goes wrong and I fall
40,000 feet from the ground,
I will die. All of you will die.
You don't have a chance of surviving.
One time, one girl fell from her airplane
and she survived and she walked to the jungle
for, I don't know, three weeks and she survived.
I don't care! God was on her side.
I don't know, Buddha was on her side.
Fucking, Satan was on her side.
Fucking, I don't know, whatever you believe in,
they were on her side. The universe hates me.
I have terrible, terrible luck with everything
in my life, okay?
Everything that's ever gone wrong in my life
has gone wrong in my life.
So,
no one will be on my side
if I fall 40,000 feet in the air, okay?
Okay.
Just boat clutch it.
I don't have a boat. I don't have a bucket of water
while I'm on the...
I don't have a boat and I don't have
a bucket of water while I'm on the airplane, okay?
I'm not ready to boat clutch and I'm not ready
to water clutch. I don't have a block
of hay with me. I don't have a block of slime
with me, okay? I'm not ready.
I'll catch you. You're gonna die, too.
Number two.
Wait, sorry, yeah. Number two.
Second line that they tell you.
Airlines do a lot of maintenance on planes.
You know, they run by fucking...
They have all these...
mechanics and all these
engineers that they hired.
Um, the...
Stop giving me advice in chat!
Mod's next person that gives me advice
in chat, ban them. I'm not getting over this fear.
Okay?
We're not here... We're here to disprove
the lies that Airlines told us, okay?
We're not here to spread them.
Thank you.
Um, okay.
You know, they tell you that they do a lot of maintenance.
There's a whole checklist of things that you...
that they check before even getting off...
uh, getting off the ground, you know?
There's always delays when you're
about to take an airplane because, you know,
they gotta check the plane before they
get off the...
the ground before they take off, you know?
Sorry, not getting off.
Take off.
Before they take off.
But the truth is,
they only care about money.
They only care about money. Okay?
Just like any other business, they only care about money.
You know who runs Airlines? Do you think
an engineer runs Airlines? No, it's some
random fucking billionaire. Do you think he cares
about your life? No. Is he gonna cut corners
where he can? Yes, absolutely
he will. Okay?
Um, if they're losing money,
they will cheap out. They will cheap out
and they will loosen the safety procedures
and they will get that plane
right back off the ground as soon
as it touches land because that's what
makes them money, okay? They will not let
that plane rest because every second
that a plane is on the ground, they are losing
money. Okay? Okay.
So, they will...
loosen their safety procedures so they can get that plane back up
in the air. And they will fire
any whistleblowers that tries to,
you know, warn them that there's something wrong,
you know?
Because you aren't doing enough checks on your planes.
Hey guys, your safety procedures aren't good enough.
They will fire those people
that do that because they're, you know,
they're not interested in keeping people
that actually care about safety, okay?
They're interested in keeping the people
that will make them money, okay?
Um, if you want proof,
see Air Alaska Flight 261,
okay? That's your proof.
Um, it, literally what I'm describing
is what happened. They fired the whistleblower
and, um...
And the plane went down
because they weren't doing maintenance
well enough.
Ah...
I have to take a breath.
I do have sources.
I do have sources. I can't hear what sources.
Of course I can't hear what sources.
You think, you think I don't do research?
I do a lot of research.
Okay.
Next.
Um...
What is the next one?
Should I get more water?
Hold on. Let me take a break.
Alright.
Number three.
They tell you, oh, if you follow
the safety procedures during an emergency,
you'll have a higher chance of living.
Sure, sure, sure.
If you survive the crash,
if you survive the crash,
and you follow the safety procedures,
maybe, maybe, but it really
all depends on the circumstance.
It really all depends on the circumstance, okay?
Because
planes will burst into flames
60 seconds or less
or less
after the crash, okay?
60 seconds or less or more,
it really, really depends, okay?
It really, everything depends on your circumstance, okay?
So, sure, you could follow every single
safety procedure, but if the plane fucking bursts
into flames, you know,
like 30 seconds after it hits the ground,
you're dead, okay? You're dead because
you're on fire.
Like, you're dead.
You don't have a water bucket around you, okay?
You're, you're burning in lava.
Okay, so,
um, if you do
survive the crash, if you do
survive the crash, on land, on land,
there's different circumstances on water.
Just use your shield.
Shield doesn't save you from fire.
The shield does not, does not
solve the fire. You will burn to a crisp.
If you do
survive the crash, somehow,
good luck trying to escape
a burning plane with 100 to 400
other people also trying to escape.
Obviously, it depends
because obviously, there could have been
people that died during the crash
and maybe there's less people, but at the same time,
a lot of people are going to try to escape
at once. Will flavor crisp?
I feel like I would be like
Hot Cheeto flavor.
Or like, cheese flavor.
I like cheese. I eat a lot of cheese.
Sigh.
Higher chance my ass goes from
1% safe to 3% safe? Exactly.
Yeah. Like, sure.
I'll, I'll follow the safety procedures
because I'm not an asshole. I'm not an idiot.
Okay, I'll follow the safety procedures. I know
every time I get on a plane, I read that
fucking booklet front to back like 15
times because I need to make sure that if
somehow I do survive the plane crash, I know what
to do to live after the plane
crashes as well. Okay.
Ahem.
A sudden barrage of kisses. I missed you. Oh, I
missed you too.
Maybe the plane crashes 100 times this week.
Oh.
Okay, number 4, Final One.
Turbulence is normal and will not make the plane fly
out of the sky.
I know turbulence is normal. Okay, I know.
I know. It happens.
It happens to every single plane, every single
fucking plane I've been on, I've been
bounced around like a fucking volleyball.
Every single plane I've been on I've been
ass fucked by my seat because
The truth, the truth, why does turbulence make me feel like I'm falling out of the sky?
I know why it makes me feel like I'm falling out of the sky, but that's why you feel like
you're falling when you're in an elevator.
You feel the change, you know, you feel the change, your body feels it because objects
that are in motion stay in motion, whatever the fuck, I don't care, but it makes me feel
like I'm falling out of the sky and that makes me, oops, and that makes me, my phone
is about to die, that makes me uncomfortable, that makes me uncomfortable, I don't want
to feel like I'm falling out of the sky while I'm on a plane.
Is that bad?
Is it so bad to not want to feel like I'm falling out of the sky while I'm on a plane?
That's literally 40,000 feet in the air, because that makes me uncomfortable, and, and, and
the, the, the, k tipped $5, turbulence is God's way of reminding humans they don't belong
in the sky.
It's the fucking, it's the, it's nature's way of reminding humans that you're not supposed
to be here, and that's why it's trying to make you uncomfortable because you're not
supposed to be here, you're supposed to be on land, you don't have wings, get out of
the fucking sky.
Okay, anyways, um, for what I was going to say, also, also, sometimes it might be turbulence,
but sometimes it might be something else, sometimes something could be going wrong,
and you know what the, the pilots are going to say, nothing, the pilots are going to say
shit to you, you think they're going to get on the fucking radio and they're going to
be like, alright guys, so, um, actually, uh, our left wing exploded and we are, um, struggling
to keep the plane in the air, um, yeah, please put on your seatbelt, no, they probably won't
say that, they probably won't say that, they'll probably put on the fucking fasten seatbelt
sign, they'll ask the flight attendants to make sure everyone's in their seat, and then
they'll figure it out from there because they don't want people freaking the fuck out,
you know?
They don't, they don't want people freaking the fuck out, that would feel more than turbulence,
I know, I know, I know, I know, I would feel like more than turbulence, but I'm just saying,
I felt really bad turbulence before, I have felt really, because I've been on really small
planes before, and like, smaller planes, I feel like you're more affected by turbulence
on smaller planes, so it's like, I felt myself falling out of the sky for like, multiple
seconds on tiny, tiny planes, and like, sure, it could be that, you know, it's just turbulence,
but it could also be that one of the engines just went out, you know?
Because when an engine goes out, then it does, it does, it does lower the plane, because
obviously the plane cannot stay up at a high altitude when there's only one engine going,
you know?
Besides, isn't the autopilot flying like 85, it is, yes, yes, usually autopilot is doing
its thing, but sometimes autopilot will force you to do its own thing because something
went wrong.
As I've watched the video literally today, the autopilot was not turning off, because
there was an explosion in the plane, and it fucked with the fucking circuits, and they
couldn't control the fucking plane, because the autopilot went off, went on, and it wouldn't
turn off.
You cannot, you don't, I don't trust autopilot, I don't trust autopilot, don't trust machines,
don't trust machines, I don't trust humans either, because obviously there's the case
of that one pilot being really suicidal, and literally driving the plane into the earth
because he was suicidal, I don't trust either.
I got to work with a guy who worked on Aerolasca 261, nice guy, quit that shop when a wheel
fell off our plane mid-flight and hit a swimming pool.
Yeah, yeah, um, what was I saying?
I completely forgot, thank you for the five dollars though.
Uh-huh, I've seen autopilot fight against the pilots, it can happen, computers, computers,
you know, break sometimes, and sometimes the computer will take over and will not let
you control, you know?
Um, there's been a bunch of plane crashes because pilots did stupid shit like letting
their kids fly the plane, that's also why I don't trust humans, because I literally
saw that story a while ago, some fucking guy was flying the plane, he was like a copilot
or something, or like, they have like two pilots on a plane or something, I don't know.
And so while one of the pilots left, he fucking called his kids up to the cockpit and was
like, hey, come over here kids, let me help you fly the plane, let me show you how to
fly the plane.
He let his daughter go first, and of course, as a responsible child, she does not touch
the wheel, okay, she just kind of sits there, and you know, doesn't really do much because
you're a fucking child, like don't let your kids fly a fucking plane, but then of course
he brings his son up, and like the stupid kid his son is, grabs the fucking wheel and
like turns it all sorts of ways, and then they go flying out of the air, and they can't
get control of the plane anymore, and they die, they die, because humans are stupid and
they do stupid shit, okay?
So I don't trust a human to run a plane, I don't trust a machine to run a plane because
I don't trust being in a plane, because it's dangerous.
What was I talking about?
Yeah, I've heard the saying, oh turbulence is just like road bumps, it's basically just
like bumps in the road, but when I'm in the road, and I'm driving, and I go over a bump,
I don't feel like I'm falling out of the sky, okay, usually I don't even feel like
I'm falling, because it's never a big bump like that.
Well, what happened?
Wait, oh wait, that happened?
Yes, it did.
Some stupid pilot let his kids fly the plane and they died.
You're clearly not driving fast enough?
I'm not, because I'm a safe driver, okay?
I drive at the speed limit, or maybe a little bit over, but I'm a safe driver.
My elbow was speeding the whole time, that's another reason I was getting nauseous, because
he's like a really shitty driver, and he speeds all the time, and he just drives bad in general.
Alright, there we go, that's that slide, next slide, alright.
Everything that can go wrong will go wrong, everything that has gone wrong will go wrong
again.
I don't know that fucking saying anything that can happen will happen, yes, yes, any stupid
shit that you think might happen on the plane probably has happened before, and it probably
will happen again, and it could happen to you, it could happen to any one of us.
Yes, Murphy's Law.
Next, oh sorry, alright, a law can go wrong, a lot, every, obviously it's a machine, so
any sort of mechanical thing can go wrong, but I'm going to tell you other ways it can
go wrong too.
Hijacking, hijacking used to be so fucking common back in like the 70s, it was crazy.
Plays used to get hijacked all the fucking time, obviously not anymore, not as much anymore,
but it still happens, because recently, globally there's been at least one a year, at least
one usually, sometimes more, sometimes two or three, that's recent.
Now you could be that one, or that two, you could be on two, you could have been on both
planes that got hijacked, and you know, you're at the mercy of the hijackers, they can do
whatever the fuck they want, I saw, I was watching, can you tell I'm a big fan of the
show Mayday?
Mayday is a show about plane crashes, I literally watched a hijacking story, right, and some
stupid dumb ass hijackers hijacked the plane, right, and they were like, take us to Australia,
and this plane was in Africa somewhere I think, I don't remember where, the plane was over
Africa I think, and obviously planes don't hold extra fuel really, because obviously
like why would the airline waste money and give them extra fuel, they hold a little bit
of extra fuel, but not a lot, not a lot, because that's you know, you don't want to waste money
holding extra fuel, right, so the plane only had enough fuel for like two hours of a drive,
of a flight, okay, because their destination was like two hours away, right, and the hijackers
hijacked the plane, and they were like, drive us, drive us, fly us to Australia right now,
or else we'll fucking kill everyone on this plane, we'll you know, we'll defuse a bomb
on this plane and everyone's gonna die, and so the pilots literally had to fly the plane
into the ocean, because they were forced to fly into the ocean, but they didn't have
enough fuel to you know, get to Australia, because they didn't they didn't fuel the plane
enough, and that's fine, I'm fine with not having that much extra fuel, but I'm scared
of hijacking, of course I'm scared of being hijacked, are you kidding me, I literally
watched this story, one time of this lady from the show I survived, her plane got hijacked,
they landed the plane safely, but then they fucking, the police were trying to negotiate
with the hijackers, and every time the negotiations went wrong, they would literally bring a passenger
up to the exit of the plane, and shoot the passenger in the head, and then push them
out of the plane into a pile of other dead people that they shot in the head for the
negotiations going wrong, like I'm afraid of hijackers, and I can't escape a hijacker
when I'm in the air, you know, like if I'm in a bus and it gets hijacked, like I can
still escape because I'm on the ground, you know, but if I'm in a plane, I'm in the air,
there's no way of escaping a hijacker, I'm at their mercy, you know, I mean you're still
at the mercy of a hijacker, like if you're on the ground, but you're less at their mercy
because you're on the ground, and you can run away if you find a way to get out, you
know, I forgot that your 747 could be smuggling illegal smoke nades that go off in the back
by accident and crash the thing from smoke and flames, you're talking about like, I
don't know what smoke nade is, I don't know what that is, cars have four doors, planes
have one, planes don't have one door, they have more than one door, often planes have
like, one, two, three, four, maybe like six exits, I think, nades, oh grenades, oh nades,
oh nade, nades, I mean it is nades, nades, it's like what the fuck is a nades, how am
I supposed to know that nades, how am I supposed to know it's pronounced nades, nades, how
am I supposed to know that, who, who, who pronounces, like who shortens grenades to nades, who
does that, suddenly Espanol, who shortens grenades to nades, I never heard that before,
if they only had one door it would take three hours to get everyone off the plane, oh wait
no they still, it still takes forever to get off a plane because they only let you out
through the one door, the other doors are for emergencies, you know, gamers, gamers, I'm
not a gamer, so how am I supposed to know that nades is pronounced nades, it sounds
like aids, whatever, whatever, okay here's some technical issues that I've seen stories
about, first one, a tiny little crack in the plane can make the whole fucking roof break
off, see aloha airlines flight 243, they had, I don't know what was wrong exactly, they
had small cracks in the plane and something happened, like the cabin depressurized or
something because of that, like if there's a hole in the plane like it's bad, like people
get sucked out, you know, because the plane is going so fast, so what ended up happening
was like the roof of the half of, the roof of the front half of the plane literally ripped
off while they were in the air, right, and the plane was like hanging on by a thread,
the front of the plane where the pilots were was like hanging off, hanging on by a thread
because it was like, you know, it didn't have as much support anymore, right, so when it
ripped off, like when the roof ripped off, the flight attendants were literally like
going to people that were sitting on the plane and they were like, does anyone know how to
fly a plane here, because they didn't know if they had pilots still or not, you know,
didn't it kill a steward, I think it did, I think it did, mayday watch along, you want
to watch mayday with me, usually on big planes they use the missed front and rear ones, but
yeah, it takes a while, oh, like the exits, I've only been on planes where they used one
exit to get everyone off the plane afterwards, but yeah, and and like it was like they were
racing to land this plane because it was about to break in half in the sky, you know, that's
terrifying, and also if you do, you know, if your plane does, if the roof of your plane
does come off, you can't breathe up there, it's too fast and there's the air pressure
is like really, I think low, like there's not enough oxygen up there for you to breathe,
okay, so you just die, 243 they used a metal scraper to remove sealant, this cut through
the special coating that protects the metal from elements, so the metal got wet started
to rust and gave out, mm-hmm, any tiny thing that goes wrong can cause like a huge effect
on the plane, here, some idiot forgetting to uncover the air pressure sensors, it can
make the like the height meter, because the air pressure sensors is how the plane senses
how high it is in the air, and they can it can make the the sensors not work anymore,
and so the pilots don't know how high they are in the air, and I saw a story about that,
I don't remember which flight it was, I got I couldn't I couldn't look for it, but some
maintenance asshole put some tin foil or something on the air pressure sensors and forgot to
take it off, and so as they were taking off the computers on the plane were like, oh you're
too high in the sky, I think that was it, you're too high in the sky, right, so the
pilots of course trusting the computer on the plane started to descend, and so then the
other sensor went off, and it was like, oh you're too low in the sky, and then both sensors
were going off, like both alarms were going off saying you're both too high in the sky
and too low in the sky, and they didn't know what to do, because what are you supposed to do,
and they don't know how high they are in the sky, because they can't see anything, you
can't really you can't actually see anything when you're that high in the sky, you know,
and so they kept going down and down and down until they eventually just crashed into the
ocean, and I'll talk about ocean crashes because those are really scary, can't they see how
high they are, no they couldn't, because they were above the ocean, and I think it was like,
if it's nighttime you can't see anything, you really can't see anything, especially when
you're above the ocean, the ocean is like pitch black at night, like you really can't see
anything when you're in the ocean at night, like if you're in the middle of the ocean, if you're
near civilization, I'm sure you could see lights, but they were in the middle of the ocean, you
can't see anything, alright, and that's how they crash into the water. Next, if the inside of,
I wrote plain wrong, I wrote, I have a lot of typos in this, just jumping in to say I
completely agree with this, I have a fear of flying in planes as well, it is completely
rational, thank you, it is rational, it is rational, if the inside of the plane isn't
pressurized correctly, you brain, why are you acting so gay, something original tip $20,
don't forget about all the times that one plane just smashed into another one because one of
the pilots fucked up, you can die even if your pilot didn't do anything wrong, I know that one,
I know that one, yeah, one plane just crashed, and there were two really big planes and they
just crashed into each other, I don't remember exactly what the story was, I have to, I have
to think of, I have to watch the video again, but yeah, it was, it was something like that,
like two planes like crashed into each other, like in the sky, I think a plane crashed in
Brazil last week and everyone died, that's what I'm saying, plane crashes are so deadly,
so deadly, like if something goes wrong, like you're a dead man, at that point,
I'm gonna go get more water and then I'll continue, hold on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
yeah
why is it why is it black on screen
I have a green screen somewhere do I have a green screen I do have a green screen there we go okay there we go sorry about sorry about that I don't know I have a green screen there was a green screen on the capture um reminds me of driving
yeah
you don't notice this happening until it's too late spirit spirit has cheap seats and then make their money back nickel and diming every extra yeah yeah yeah
okay finally finally you will die if it crash lands you will die and you may think to yourself but I'm in my seat with my seat belt in and you know
okay what's the 40k meme I don't understand I don't understand what that means what is 40k I'm talking about 40,000 feet in the air I people keep saying 40k I don't know what that means I'm out of the loop here warhammer 40k what is the meme though what is the
what is the meme what like what is this some sort of meme I don't understand what is that it's a gamer meme they're just being artistic I can tell I can tell Chad is always a little artistic
table top board board game people just get excited when you say the number okay okay seat belts are almost like a placebo or for turbulence if the plane goes down you'll die yes yes the seat belts are there to fucking keep your body from like being identified
they're there to keep your body from being identifiable okay because if you're in the bathroom I have that as the last point if you're in the bathroom or something while it's happening or if you're running around up and down the plane while
it's happening your body's gonna get destroyed you know you're gonna you're gonna crumple up in little pieces and then they're not gonna find your body right or there's another theory I don't know if it's true I don't know if I
really believe it but you know how they tell you oh if the plane is going down put your put the top of your head against the the front of your seat you know and cover your head yes you should cover your head if the plane is going
down because if stuff is flying around which it will it will fly around if the plane goes down and it hits your head you know that's very bad and you could die from that but the thing of like putting
your head like the top of your head on the front of the seat I've heard that they want you to like do that because when
the plane finally hits the ground the seats are all gonna you know be pushed back like the the the back of the seats are all gonna be pushed back right at once and they want you to do that so you break your neck
and don't sue them they want you to do that so you die and then you can't sue them for the plane crash
mm-hmm mic drop yep I've heard of that because um the flight attendants take a different like the flight attendants have different
positions for emergencies like why would you put your the top of your head you know why would you stick the top of your head
in front like against the front of your of the seat in front of you I mean against the back of the seat in front of you like why would you do that
you're just asking for your neck to break when we hit the ground you know like they're asking for your neck to break you're asking for your neck to break
just put your table up like I'll talk about it here putting your table up doesn't do anything putting your table up is so that your table like doesn't hit you you know
um alright so once again 40,000 feet in the air obviously it could be 30,000 something I don't think they go higher than 40,000 or maybe they go 50,000 I don't know they go high up
and the reason they do that I don't think they go 50,000 I don't know but the reason they go so high up in the air because that's really fucking high up in there that's higher than the clouds
okay the reason they go that higher high up in the air is because the air is thinner up there so they're able to go faster with less gas and so they do that to save on gas
yeah so you know they get you that high up in the air or you're absolutely gonna die if something goes wrong and you crash just to save some fucking money
and I know it's like oh but you get to your destination faster I don't care I don't care I don't care if I get to my destination faster I want to be closer to the ground so I live okay okay
what about airplane mode on my phone that's faking gay that doesn't do anything
airplane mode doesn't do shit airplane mode is so that your phone provider doesn't charge you for being in a different country
at least yeah right your your cell phone providers like charge you for entering a different country and getting texts in different countries
there you go that's what you can use airplane mode for
anyways yeah normalize airplanes being lower down in the air I don't care if it takes longer for me to get to my destination
I don't want to be so fucking high that I can see space okay I don't want to be that high in the air
that's scary okay anyways so yeah that's why they go so high in the air to save on gas maybe to go faster I don't care I don't care
I don't want to I don't even want to go that fucking fast why are we going so fucking fast in the air it's like 3,000 kilometers per hour or something I don't know
why are we going so fucking fast slow down okay like whatever
so landing in the ocean right let's say you land in the ocean you might think oh but we're in the ocean so like
you know we're not going to hit a bunch of stuff on the way down you know because if you land on on the on the ground
you're going to hit trees you're going to hit because obviously you're crash landing right in the situation we crash landing
you're not you're not at uh you're not at a landing strip right you're going to hit trees you're going to help you're going to hit houses
you're going to hit cars or maybe you're going to hit like a field if you're fucking lucky a flat field
but probably not um or um so instead of that you might think oh maybe landing in the ocean is better
because you won't be hitting all this stuff on the way down and so your plane isn't gonna fall apart
while you're like hitting or mountains even you can even hit mountains when you're on the on the
way down right if you're landing in the ocean it's just as bad or i guess even more dangerous than
on the ground is what i wrote here because a lot of airplanes have their engines um right underneath
the wings right those are where the engines are they're attached to the bottom of the wings
so what happens is as the plane is falling into the water the engine the water will like the
engine one will hit the water first like the engines are one of the first things that hit the
water right the bottom of the plane or or the engine and all the water is going to go rushing
into the engine of the plane and it's just going to rip the engine like it's going to rip the plane
apart you know because it's like stopping the plane and planes go really really fucking fast
and so obviously the plane is not going to be able to withstand all of that um
all of that like force and it's going to rip and rip in pieces go lower and spend
way more time in the plane no thank you if i feel safer i'd rather spend more time
and also make the seats bigger but it doesn't matter because they're never gonna do that
they're never gonna do either of those things
oh this thing right it's gonna tear the plane apart and you're gonna end up
fucking jostled around in a torn apart plane and let's say you got really unlucky and you
landed in the middle of the fucking ocean the middle of but fuck nowhere in the ocean okay
you got really unlucky nowhere near any sort of island nowhere near any sort of like coastline
you're just in the middle of the but fuck ocean right you better hope you're on some sort of boat
you better hope you're on some sort of safety raft obviously there's safety rafts in in um
in planes if they do land on the water sure there's safety rafts but the chance of the
plane landing safely on the water so that the safety rafts can deploy are probably minimal okay
they're probably minimal if you have to crash land into the freaking water the plane is destroyed
it in pieces right okay so you better hope that you're you have some sort of thing to hang on to
that's floating because it'll take multiple hours to even days for a rescue to come and
save you guys and if you're in cold water then you're just dead okay just you know like
there is no there is no jack what's it called jack and rose no titanic that's not happening
okay rose is dying okay both of you are dying um because you'll die in like 45 minutes in cold
water right we need a sad violin trains cars planes i i'm okay with trains trains are okay
uh trains are okay i don't mind trains but yeah you'll die in like 45 minutes in cold water basically
and if you are a dumbass if you were a dumbass and i am a dumbass and lots of people are dumbasses
in this world if you were a dumbass and you didn't read the safety instructions and you inflated your
life jacket before exiting the plane okay and you're crash landing into the ocean you're also dead
because dead you're also dead because water is going to come rushing into the plane
and you're going to be forced to the top you're going to be forced to the top and sure the plane
is in pieces but the part of the plane you're in might not be in pieces okay the part of the plane
you're in might still be pretty you know put together you might not have fallen out of the plane
and you're you have your life raft i mean your life jacket already inflated you're going to just
get pushed all the way to the ceiling and you're not going to be able to escape you're not going
to be able to escape because you can't fight the life jacket to swim so you're basically just drowning
you're forced to sit there and drown okay okay that's natural selection i'm a dumb bitch okay i
when you're when you're freaking out when you're panicking your you do stupid shit when you're
panicking okay you do stupid shit and and that's understandable and i i feel bad for anyone that's
been on a plane and crash landed into the ocean and inflated their life jacket before falling
into the ocean because i would probably do the same because i'm freaking the fuck out and i don't
want to die and the life jacket has the word life in it and i want i don't i any i want to keep my
life okay okay crash landing in on random land you better hope you have multiple kilometers
multiple okay i'm going to use my little i'm going to use my little my little hat to point
multiple kilometers of flat space to land on otherwise you're just going to crash into everything
and also tear the plane apart planes cannot land on the ground really they need a landing
strip they need they need an airport to land at if something goes wrong they can't just be like okay
emergency landing on the ground no if something goes wrong wrong they have to go to the nearest
airport there's no emergency landing on the ground there's emergency landing at the nearest airport
you know if they can control the plane obviously if they can control the plane they go to the closest
airport that they can okay but if they can't control the plane then they have to just fucking
crash into the ground of course and you're not going to live because the plane will tear apart
while you're crashing into the ground because the chances of having you know multiple kilometers of
flat space for land on a highway you're crashing into all the fucking cars in the highway like
there's gonna be explosions there's gonna be the plane breaking apart okay even yeah even on a landing
strip if the gear messes up you can it can still be catastrophic there was one case of uh there was
one Mayday episode I saw where they they still had a landing strip but because I think the problem
was that because it was so dark um they landed on the landing strip too late right and it was like
raining or something or like frozen like cold rain so it was getting frozen on the landing strip
and so they were like gliding on the landing strip and they couldn't stop in time and they like
they kept they kept the plane kept you know going on the ground after the strip ended and they
crashed into some trees or something and like people died like like like emergency landings
or just regular landings can go wrong horrifically wrong you know all right here it is the human
body can only survive an acceleration of around four to nine G's oh but my uncle survived an
acceleration of 12 G's I don't care I'm not your fucking uncle okay I'm a fragile fragile piece of
human meat he said 25 dollars listening to a cute and nerdy girl you have about white airplanes
our bad has made my absolute say Tism Tism Tism thank you for the 25 dollars Tism I'm a fragile
piece of human meat okay I will rip apart at the smallest tiniest paper cut I got a cardboard
cut before cardboard has cut me okay do you know how hard it is to get cut by a piece of cardboard
it's really fucking hard so I will not I probably won't even survive four G's okay
plane crashes can go up to like 200 G's like I'm not you're not surviving that crash you know
some people have but you're not one of them and I'm not one of them we're not lucky like that
or maybe you are lucky like that I don't know you but I'm not lucky like that I've never been
looking my entire life so yeah um the acceleration will just kill you yeah and finally what what is
the last one there it is if you're not sitting in your seat and you're gonna die like imagine being
in the bathroom shitting and pooping your pants and it flies everywhere and you die that's embarrassing
okay what I'm trying to say here listen I wrote this like two seconds before stream what I'm trying
to say here is imagine you're in the bathroom right you're not in your seat you're in the bathroom
and you're shitting and then suddenly the plane starts going down and you have no control over
like where you're going because you're like you you hit the ceiling because you're not strapped to
your you know chair you hit the ceiling your shit hits the ceiling with you your piss hits the
ceiling with you and then finally you know the plane crashes and you die in your you die surrounded
by your own piss and shit with your pants down that's embarrassing that's embarrassing that's how
Elvis died that's embarrassing you know I don't I want to if I do crash I want to look cute I want
my body to look cute I don't want to die in an embarrassing way because like I'm I'm honestly
already shy I haven't died yet but I'm shy of the fucking coroner seeing my dead naked body
you know like imagine dying in that way that's so embarrassing
oh there you go and that's that's my um presentation thank you for listening um
any questions any concerns that I can address you know please ask them now I will answer them to
the best of my ability yeah gotta look your best I just want to look cute you know it's embarrassing
it's kind of embarrassing to die because you know you shit yourself after you die and you piss yourself
after you die like that's embarrassing I want to at least look pretty when I do it you know
question I love you Imi I love you too um that's on a hot air balloon I never been on a hot air
balloon and I never really want to I don't really trust a hot air balloon either
well you hold my hand while we fly I will be I will be clutching that hand and squeezing
so hard I will be squeezing the shit out of your hand like you're gonna be in pain
thanks for educating me I've always been more scared of boats but now I'm scared of planes as
well good you should be scared of both I'm scared of boats too um I'm scared of boats too yeah
yeah every time I'm on a boat I'm thinking like fuck would I be able to swim out of here
and the answer is usually no because water is actually a lot more dangerous than you think
like water can be really really aggressive and strong and even even some olympics olympic
swimmers will not be able to fight those kind of currents you know can we survive if we jump
right before the plane is the ground no you can't use elevator logic in a plane no
no I never had the need to go on a plane but now I'll make certain the need never arises good
stay safe don't believe the airlines don't believe the government okay they want your money and they
just want to make sure you don't sue them I'm scared of fights but I love traveling so yeah
I have no choice take a boat I'm less scared of a boat than I am of a plane I I don't know why
but I I mean it makes sense like you're not going to crash into a million pieces if something
goes wrong on a boat you know thank you for becoming a member jokes on you I'm not disillusioned
with the idea that life is worth living booking a flight right now if you if you're if you want to die
go ahead I won't stop you be a sheeple be a sheeple and follow everyone else
but us alphas okay us us lone wolves will be living surviving thriving not on a plane
what would it take for you to skydive fucking I have cancer and I'm dying tomorrow that would
that's what it would take for me to skydive okay that's what it would take for me to skydive
otherwise I'm not doing it I get very seasick easily though planes are better
all take a gravel I'm no puke deal with it that's what I would do at least
does the blue check mark on brosley mean you got verified oh
um let me go back to the chatting hold on
maybe I thought I didn't know it would be that quick I thought it would take more time
let me try let me see what's going on would I get an email I feel like I would get an email
um oh your application has been approved hey got approved yeah that's so surprising wait
that's so quick I applied oh my god I got up I got uh I got accepted like
less than 20 minutes after applying what the hell I put a lot of effort in my application
they asked you to send a video of yourself and I made sure I looked cute in that video
and I was like hi my name's Amy I hope a real human is watching this video because I put a lot of
effort and I showed my ID so good I put so much effort into taking that selfie they ask for a lot
they ask for a lot of things for you and I put a lot of effort into my application
but yeah I guess it's um I guess it's uh yeah I'm verified now um whoa I can like post stuff
now I can post stuff I'm not gonna post the link here because uh I don't think I'm allowed to
but I will let you know how do I set up subscription tiers oh I have to like
I have to set up a lot huh I have to set everything up first and test it before I actually do
a stream there I'm putting in my socials hold on
you worked so hard I did
right I have to set up like I don't know I don't know if people I don't know what people want from
me I'm nervous for it and I I'll probably be really nervous and and awkward and and shaky
I might not do something too crazy for like the first stream oh my god she be following me on
fansly I gotta follow she be too damn she's got 2,000 followers on fan I mean brosley
brosley I should oh wow she has like an actual bio oh oh I should make an actual bio
damn she be popping off on fansly I I'm not allowed to link my fansly anywhere
not even on Twitter the struggle why do I have a dm followers oh my god she set
she set up wow she set up like an automatic dm damn shebe's like
free messaging wait do I have to tip $5,000 to she be to talk to her come on she be
um that's cool she set up an automatic dm that says like thank you for following that's so cool
wow I have to actually put an effort into my um I have to start putting effort into into my
brosley holy crap
it's nervous I mean it's normal to be nervous I know I know but I'm gonna be really nervous
you could use a link tree I could I I'll I'll
I don't know I don't know how I'll grow there I don't know how I'll grow there at all to be
honest I probably won't be able to grow much there which is why I won't use it too much
but we'll have a little bit of fun there every now and then and I'll I'll give you a good uh
I'll give you a good uh
I'll give you a good enough warning hopefully of like when I plan one there
real pricey conversation I know Mercy is like a hundred k
or what holy wait what
mercy let me go follow the other girls actually I think it's just she be in mercy right
hey mercy mercy doesn't have a hundred k followers don't scare me like that oh wait do you mean a
hundred k to dm mercy don't worry immy it's normal to be nervous take it at your own pace
do what you feel like doing smiley face oh thank you thank you for the five dollars
you had me thinking mercy had a hundred k followers on fancy and I was like holy
shit wow
okay I'll have to ask her for help because I don't know
um I don't know how to use it at all I really don't know how to use it at all at all at all
I've never touched this website at all before I see still setting up hers don't know about Azura
yeah I think I see still doing hers I'm not sure if Azura will do it I don't know
she would quit youtube at that point I hope not I hope she stays here with us don't quit for
don't quit for brosley stay on youtube please don't leave us
PewDiePie would get a hundred k well what the fuck would PewDiePie make
everyone's over there already just by substituting names in the url yeah yeah yeah they um they
saved our names for us um that's why we all have accounts it's just it's up to us whether or not
we want to use the accounts you know and I will I will I will um eventually when I figure out
when I have time to set it up and when I figure out how to set it up
I have to go thank you for the stream it's oh sorry
the timer to give Esavon her medicine just went off um so I'll probably also go here
but thank you for coming to the stream um
Strani is streaming so we'll write Strani unless she's ending
no I don't think she's ending we can write Strani
I hope you enjoyed the stream check out your brosley when I oh I'll check it out when I get home
tonight okay good check it out if you have time if you want to that is um you don't have to
I'm not there's nothing there yet there's nothing there yet I just got verified just today um
um excuse me all right I set it up to write Strani
anything
give us some kisses for me I've been giving her lots of kisses
usually she doesn't like being touched but she's been extra um
she's been extra cuddly which worries me
because that's completely out of character for her so yeah um are you afraid of boats on the ocean
I am but not as afraid of boats as I am of airplanes I'm more afraid of planes for sure
yeah when non cuddly animals get extra cuddly it's scary it is scary like she's not acting like
herself so I'm worried um did that save it's not saving hello that isn't available what oh no it worked
okay can you hear Strani right now no you can't okay thank you for the totally accurate totally
real info on the aviation industry it is accurate and real I provide my sources go check out my sources
if you doubt me if you're doubting me go go look up my sources and the stories that other people
have talked about too go look up those ones and then you'll see that it's real it's real and it can
happen to you and it can happen to any one of us okay it's accurate 100 accurate I didn't say anything
wrong and no lies were told in this stream I told you I told you only the truth something something
nothing but the truth source cute sister exactly I am the source and I am correct all the time
I never lie I would never lie to you I care about your safety that's why I'm telling you all this
stuff so that you know to be safe okay okay so um be safe don't get on an airplane don't get on a boat
um yeah and I'll see you again tomorrow for an ASMR stream you will hate planes and you will love
me yes you will hate planes and you will love me okay okay I'll see you tomorrow for the ASMR
stream have a have a good evening or afternoon or morning I don't know I'll see you tomorrow okay
bye love you I miss you so much I'm so happy to be back oh my god
you
You